acompañamos a un grupo de manifestantes
a una de las tantas marchas que se están
celebrando de forma simultánea en el
centro de beirut para reclamar justicia
por las víctimas del puerto de beirut
por las 215 personas que murieron el 4
de agosto del año pasado después de un
año las autoridades prometieron que en
cinco días se conocerían las causas de
esta explosión pero un año después
todavía los libaneses se siguen
preguntando qué ocurrió ese 4 de agosto
los libaneses culpan a la élite
gobernante de haber conducido al país a
la ruina total de haber no protegido de
forma deliberada a sus ciudadanos al
haber permitido que dos mil setecientos
cincuenta toneladas de nitrato de amonio
explotaron en el centro de beirut es por
eso que hoy los libaneses se han unido
para pedir justicia y para recordar a
las víctimas de esta tragedia porque si
no es así
la explosión del puerto de beirut podría
caer en el olvido institucional ya que
las autoridades están obstruyendo la
investigación al no levantar la
inmunidad procesal a los altos cargos
imputados